Năm chỉnh đặc mồ tình tại chính đất và pháp khẳng đệnh tất nước chỗ ông sẽ không khót phục chương những đe dù át hối từ Mỹ,
liên quan tới Greenland, nhấn mạnh, liên mình chỗ ông sẽ có phản đúng thống nhất và sâu sàng.
Thế biểu tại Berlin, bố chính tại chính đất Ló S.C.B.B.T.B.
Đức và pháp sẽ không chính nhận bị công tiền, bố chính tại chính pháp Ruralar Rescue Giang,
biệt rồi sẽ kẹp dưới cơ động mình là điều không thể chính nhận.
Theo khi hoạch, các nhà lãnh đỏ ai uống sẽ thảo lợp biển pháp ứng phó tạo vì thím định khân cấp ở Bruce S.
và hỗy tuần này, một sân án là tài khi khoản gọi thủy trị giá chimpanzee Rural,
đối với hạn hoạm Mỹ, sau thời gian định chỉ sống tháng.
Lờ trình khác là công cổ trong cửa nghe của ayu, cho phép phản trế tiếp cận đấu thổ cân, đấu tư,
nâng hộn thương mại sĩ của pháp trở biết công cổ trong cửa nghe truyếu mang tình ra nè,
nhưng cần được xem xét trường bối cảnh hiện này, đồng thời mạnh có mồn quanh hiện suy đã tây dương trở lại liên tàn đối thoại,
thay vì để gióa, đất nhấn mạnh, ayu không tìm tích lều tháng cần thằng sống khẩn đèn cho ông không yếu và sẵn sàng bảo vệ lợi của mình.
Chứ đó, tổng thống mì đô nên trong tiên bố sẽ ăn đặt các mức thủy ra tăng, đối với hạn hoạm tình của số động mình cho ông,
cho đến khi Washington sở rữ huyên lên.